all right max we've had about a day to
play with Watson I'm not gonna lie I
don't think either of us are completely
sold on this character yet in apex
legends season two but you know we
usually do these guys where we break
down all their abilities I think what
we're gonna start this guide off with is
what's more interesting about Watson
which is what she can do with her
tactical the perimeter security these
are the fence poles that she can connect
up to about 12 of them in a match we've
had sort of mixed results with these but
you've discovered some really
interesting things with these so let's
break down the poles and the basics of
how they work yeah so the poles you can
put out 12 of them total for immediately
when they have a recharge cooldown you
can pair them with enemy fences they can
destroy doors they do ten damage per
tick
they stun they also ping enemies to your
whole team you have a couple uses as
well besides just being events yeah they
were pretty interesting they set off
caustic traps I've also seen what looked
like mirages hologram setting them off
so he can set up kind of a trick play
and the fences do have a certain amount
of HP it seems like 75 they don't have
any hit marker numbers per say on how
much HP they have but the fences do have
a pretty small amount of HP and can be
shot and destroyed by enemies yeah I
think that was a big question we had
going into season 2 was can you destroy
the fences and the answer is yeah you
pretty easily so when you're placing
these fences it's important to get them
behind cover or around rocks things like
that right the game actually does have a
AoE range that it'll tell you like an
edge of a circle how far you can link
that fence so it kind of gives you a
like a gauge on on how far that reaches
these fences what they do is they buy
you space and time and what you do with
that space and time kind of determines
whether you win or lose
yeah so we've had some some good
examples where like I was able to hold a
room for quite a long time in a like a
1v3 situation and revive my teammate now
we eventually succumbed just because
they had more resources outside of the
room than we did inside of the room they
have to go through it or they have
to shoot it one of the other so it's
gonna either you're gonna hear it either
hear gunshots or you're gonna either be
known when they walk through it so it's
definitely just something just like
similar to gas traps it's area-denial
so let's talk about characters that
counter her sort of pull strategies what
characters get around it so wraith
octane pathfinder to name a few
obviously the void the grapple can go
over at Octane's old you could just jump
right over it
I mean that may put you in a bad
situation because you're in enemy lines
but you know that is a way to get into
the enemy's face if they are hiding
behind the fences you know do heal up or
to revive a teammate so there is ways to
bias you know by passive but also you
can also just walk through the fence it
doesn't do that much damage well yeah we
did some tests I think it only took off
about a half of a shield bar so it does
ten damage per tick and the tick is
fairly quick but by the time you go
through offensive maybe does like twenty
or thirty damage more than anything in
the middle firefight that's bad but just
on its own if you just need to get
somewhere and defence it in the wait you
could just walk through and just shield
sell it off it's not a huge deal her
passive is the spark of genius which
allows her to get an interception pylon
out of each ultimate accelerant which is
very useful she can hoard ultimate
accelerants and then use them all at
once if she wants the her play style is
definitely not a fragging play style
it's definitely more defensive and that
really ties in well when you have her
ultimate which is interception pylon
which is apps throw elbows out of the
sky grenades manglers ultimate
gibraltars ultimate and also recharges
your fence tactical so most most of time
when you're just walking around you can
only have four fences at a time
when you have the ultimate up you could
just show by your ultimate and just have
a bunch of fences immediately it charges
very quickly with fences so you can just
set up a base basically so if out of
pretty good success rate having just
like one areas like I defended I just
have a pylon in the middle I'd just set
up a whole bunch of fences and they just
came in towards me because we're in the
middle of the circle so that's when she
kind of shines is her defensive
tacticals but offensively
the only way I can use her offense
offensively is defense a downed enemy in
so they can't really move
we've tried yeah it's it's sort of
worked sometimes it downs them sometimes
it just elites fence them off so it's
harder to get enemies to revive them so
it's just more pressure on the enemy
which is great but it's like the old
sniper tactic of setting somebody up is
bait yeah exactly it's not yeah it's
more of a just a bait situation well as
we mentioned earlier we've had about a
you know a day with Watson and we are
really curious what you guys think of
her so far she's really good
situationally there's seems like a lot
more to discover in the way that her
abilities pair up with other characters
such as caustic but if you guys have
found out anything really cool that we
haven't covered already let us know in
the comments below and stay tuned to
GameSpot so that we can talk more about
apex legends
you